I guess I had the pleasure to welcome
you all back to paddle number four my
name is Daniel tub and I am a fellow at
the agrarian Studies program as well and
our panel today is on small-scale swine
and we just have the two panelists Robin
is presenting tomorrow so the first is
mark esic and he is a freelance writer
and editor and the author of lesser
beasts a snout to tail history of the
humble cake which just recently came out
and their second panelist is Brad Weiss
there's a professor and chair of
anthropology at William and Mary College
and the author of several books
including street Dreams and hip hop
barber shops global global fantasy and
popular practice in urban tanzania
although there's only two panelists it's
going to be the same format because we
have to leave this room on time so that
there's time for the keynotes so you'll
each gate 20 minutes and then five
minutes of questions discussion thank
you it's an honor to be here today so
this book which came out a few months
ago it's a history of pigs mostly in the
West covers about 9,000 years in sixty
thousand words and it relies heavily on
the scholarship of others so this is
some of some of those others are in the
room today at the conference so it's my
opportunity to say thank you I couldn't
have done it without you I hope I did
justice to your work and if I didn't let
me know and I'll try to fix it I'm just
going to read a few passages from the
book selected with the title of this
panel in mind it's sort of a 20-minute
forced march through the history of pig
husbandry in America a few New England
towns look like the mother country with
cows grazing on town commons overseen by
communally
tired herders but most farms told a
different story with no herders
available animals roam the woods finding
food where they could and defending
themselves against predators or not when
necessity arose of the major livestock
only hogs truly thrived on the ocean
shores pigs rated oyster banks and clam
beds in the woods they found wild peas
vetches roots and mushrooms in Carolina
and Virginia they roamed the orchards
for windfall peaches devouring the flesh
then deftly cracking the stone to get at
the kernel inside pigs were said to be
particularly particularly fond of snakes
holding them down with one hoof
administering a killing bite then
sucking them down like noodles most of
all pigs ate nuts that fell from trees
the chestnut and oak trees once
cultivated by Native Americans now
provided food for pigs a bounty
unimaginative eurasia lackadaisical
farming was a rational response to these
prevailing conditions one observer
explained that the farmers had little
incentive to improve their practices
because quote Nature has been so
profusely bountiful in bestowing the
mediums of makeshift one makeshift
solutions proved so effective when pigs
fed themselves and multiplied beyond
reckoning why trouble with fussy English
practices the quality of the animals
suffered from this hands-off approach
but the quantity did not reports from
North America echoed those from the
Caribbean 200 years before the Virginian
Robert Beverly noted quote hogs swarm
like vermin upon the earth and find
their own support in the woods without
any care of the owner there was money in
all those hogs William pension of
Springfield Mass packed huge numbers of
hogs to supply the West Indian market as
the Barbados planter explained to John
Winthrop Caribbean planter plantation
owners quote had rather buy food at very
dear rates than produce it by labor so
infinite is the profit of the sugar
works cured meat became New England's
second most important commodity for
export trailing only fish that
incidentally was part 1 colonial this is
part 2 pioneer
in the century after the American
Revolution backwoods farmer is cleared
and settled far more land than the
Germanic people of northern Europe had
managed in a millennial the American
settlers did so using what geographer
Terry Jordan Bischoff has called the
four essential elements of backwoods
farming corn axes fire and pigs early
19th century travel Diaries traced the
spread of the pig across America quote
of all the domestic animals hogs are the
most numerous Francois Andre's show
reported from Kentucky in 1802 a
traveler in Ohio in 1817 reported that
pork could be had quote in any quantity
you please because hogs quote run in the
woods in great droves in Illinois a year
later an English visitor named elias Pym
fordham commented on the fecundity of
both humans and swine quote every log
cabin is swarming with half naked
children boys of 18 build huts marry and
raise hogs and children at about the
same expense travelers accounts also
explain how those pigs were kept in
early Ohio one man observed hogs were
almost as easily raised as the deer and
thousands were never seen by their owner
until with his gun he went out and
killed her more often farmers
occasionally tossed out a little corner
salt to keep the pigs accustomed to
having people around in the spring
farmers roamed the woods to find new
piglets and notch their ears as a mark
of ownership in the fall one pioneer
said he would build a pen and leave a
gate open quote we put shelf corn in the
pen and dribbled out a few long streaks
through the woods them half wild hogs
would follow the traces of corn up to
the pen and then he would rush up and
trap them the pigs could then be
fattened on surplus corn before
slaughter the semi wild forest pig lay
at the center of American pioneer
culture Abraham Lincoln described
himself as a masked fed lawyer meaning
that he had picked up an education in
backwoods districts just as the local
pigs that themselves among the oaks and
chestnuts the Pioneers had his many name
for pigs as the Romans had for pork most
of them reflecting the animals agility
toughness and destructiveness woods pigs
were called Razorbacks painters Rovers
thistle diggers prairie sharks land
sharks land Pike sapling splitters
Railsplitters stump suckers Elm peelers
piney woods Reuters and puzzlingly but
perhaps because they were so hard to get
a grip on cucumber seeds three the
southern range like the rest of the
country southern states preserved an
open range during the colonial period
granting livestock free run of all
unfenced land most states in the east
and midwest changed course by eighteen
fifty or so giving deed holders full
control over their lands the south
though preserved preserved it's free
range customs until after the Civil War
and in some areas until after World War
two even the politically powerful
railroads had to pay damages when their
trains killed livestock when a railroad
company argued before the Georgia
Supreme Court in 1860 that a plaintiff
plaintiff had been negligent and
allowing his horse to wander into the
path of an oncoming train the justices
rejected the argument if this were true
the court wrote that a man quote could
not walk across his neighbor's
unenclosed land nor allow his horse or
his hog or his cow to range in the woods
in the south the common people's rights
in the woods which allowed them to hunt
fish and keep livestock on any unfun
fenced land were held sacred because
without those rights many would have
starved the 1850 census revealed that
per capita there were more swine in the
south than in the Corn Belt suggesting
that nearly every southerner acquired a
few pigs notched their ears and turned
them loose in the forest and the census
surely undercounted those southern pigs
since owners could easily lower their
tax bills by underreporting their pigs
quote you can keep as many pigs as you
wish and you need not feed them a German
visitor wrote in a letter home we can
live here like Lords a prosperous farmer
in the Blue Ridge Mountains described
how
burish men could move to the region and
with the aid of free mast for their hogs
build a nice little happy home he
concluded truly it is a paradise for the
poor man southern leaders began to close
the range after the Civil War and their
main purpose was to take food out of the
mouths of the poor under prevailing law
free African Americans might have
adopted the habits of plain white folk
and earned an independent living through
hurting hunting and fishing a newspaper
editor in Virginia explained the
implications of this for the southern
economy laborers he wrote if quote
furnished with free food would neglect
agriculture end quote legislators in
every state closed the range on a
county-by-county basis starting in areas
with the largest populations of freed
slaves a newspaper claimed that this
change affected only quote lousy Negroes
and lazy white men and would be good for
both now that they would find work as
sharecroppers and tenant farmers this
was indeed the effect though few black
or white would find reason to celebrate
it as poor southerners were forced into
the reetou the post reconstruction
economy pig populations began to dwindle
historians examined the six counties in
Alabama and Mississippi and found that
before the Civil War residents had owned
2.1 hogs per capita after the war it was
point for the effect on the common folk
was plain to see if travelers to the
South before the Civil War tended to
mock southerners for their laziness
those who came after pity those same
people for their poverty misery and
hunger in the 1880s one writer described
the closing of the range as quote
another step in the oppression of the
poor for the corn belt
when pioneers cleared out another type
of settler moved in the new farmers
settled the best farmland generally
river bottom lands that Native Americans
had cultivated for centuries they leap
frogged their way west settling the
valleys of the sea I dope excuse me
Miami Wabash and other rivers by the
1850s better plows made it possible to
break up the Prairie sod wetlands were
drained more trees were cleared and the
Corn Belt a continuous 500-mile region
stretching from Ohio to Iowa was formed
corn paired with pigs fuel the rapid
settlement of the u.s. an acre of corn
produced three to six times as much
grain as an acre of wheat once owned
seed of wheat might yield 50 at harvest
a single corn kernel produced 150 to 300
only rice a far more labor-intensive
crop produced at similar rates the
farmers grew breathtaking amounts of
corn but they didn't eat it they
preferred wheat bread in their minds
corn wasn't food it was feed the
practice of fattening livestock with
grain dates back at least ancient
Mesopotamia but North American farmers
were the first apply it to apply it on a
vast scale whereas South America had
become a major meat exporter raising
cattle on grass lamb Midwestern farmers
turned grassland into cornfields and fed
the corn to hogs and cattle one early
Corn Belt farmer described a system of
fattening cows and pigs together in the
same fields quote the cattle were not
housed or sheltered but simply fed twice
a day in the open lots of eight or ten
acres each with unhusked corn with the
other fodder and followed by hogs to
clean up the waste and awful there were
no barnes which kept capital costs down
and the feeding method reduced labor
costs as well rather than harvesting
ears of corn they shocked the stalks
gathering them into large upright
bundles and left them in the fields the
cattle then ate the silage as well as
the corn kernels off the ear after the
cows had eaten it was the pigs turn they
the kernels that had escaped the
attention of the cows as well as many
that had not cow digestive systems
adapted to cellulose were inefficient at
processing grains and the pigs enjoyed a
great deal of corn that had already made
one trip through a cow as historian Alan
bode has explained for cattle feeders
the prop the margin of profit was often
represented by the nutriment that his
hogs gleaned from the droppings of
steers five industrial packing the corn
belt produced so many hogs that it
required required a new method of
processing the modern line fully
developed by the 1860s started with pigs
being driven up a ramp known as the
Bridge of Sighs in Chicago to the top
floor of a two or three storey plants a
worker attached to chained to a rear leg
of each pig and hook the other end of
the chain to an overhead rail which
hoisted the animal kicking and squealing
into the air the sticker plunged a knife
into the pigs neck and blood poured out
of the wound and through a latticed
floor to be collected in barrels below
now dead the pig was plunged into a tank
20 feet long and 6 feet wide filled with
water kept near boiling by a continuous
flow of steam men standing alongside use
short poles to keep the line of hogs
bobbing along the trough rolling them
over to ensure an even scald that would
loosen the hair at the end of the tank a
rake like device lifted the carcass and
dumped it on to an inclined table with
eight or nine men on ice on each side
their job was to scrape off the Hogs
hair the first two took only the
bristles valuable for use and brushes
along the spine the carcass then slit or
rolled down to the next men in the line
who used short-handled hose or sharp
knives to scrape and shave the hair from
every bit of the pig at the end of the
table two men attached to stick call the
gambrel that stretched the rear legs
apart then hook the gambrel to an
overhead track known as the railroad so
that the pig swung free of the table
hanging from its blade feet propelled by
gravity or a steam-driven chain the pig
carcass started down the line at the
first station two men sprayed it with
cold water to wash away loose hair and
filth then the railroad made a series of
stops at
or foot intervals the dry shaver removes
stray hairs the gut man slashed the
belly open with a single stroke allowing
the intestines to pour out the organ man
removed the heart liver and other
innards finally another man with the
hose sprayed out the interior of the
carcass each worker had just 12 seconds
to perform his task the hog then rolled
off to the cooling room to await
butchery the next day the first true
assembly line is credited to the one
that made Model T's and Henry Ford later
claimed that the idea was borrowed in
part from pork packers a moving line of
pigs or cars not only cut down on heavy
lifting but also set the pace of the
work each slaughterhouse worker had just
seconds to reform his task before
another pig arrived it was rough on the
it was rough on the workers but the rate
of production soared the genius of the
packers disassembly line and the Model T
assembly line Ford explained layin there
bringing quote the work to the men
instead of the men to the work the pork
line became a standard stop for
journalists and tourists visiting
Chicago great as this wonderful city is
and everything a British traveller said
the first the first place among its
strong points must be given to the
celerity and comprehensiveness of the
Chicago style of killing hogs that
comprehensiveness extended to the use of
the carcass the list of by-products is
nearly endless bristles became brushes
finer hair stuffed mattresses tankage
the solid bits strained from rendered
fats were ground into feed for pigs and
chickens bones were stamped in the
buttons cooked to make gelatin or
smoldered into charcoal for use in sugar
refining hooves were boiled down for
glue prussian blue a dye used by
printers was derived from blood extracts
from glands and organs pepsin and other
enzymes various hormones and more served
as raw materials for the pharmaceutical
industry pig byproducts gave Packers an
incentive to grow large small-scale
slaughtering didn't produce a marketable
amount of blood hair or bones but
killing thousands of animals a day
changed the
equation a large packinghouse might pay
ten dollars for a live hog and sell its
meat for 975 but it didn't lose money
the profit margin came from selling the
byproducts that small Packers threw away
that meant big Packers could pay higher
prices for pigs allowing them to force
out smaller competitors Cincinnati
Packers in the 1850s paid on average
five percent more than competitors
elsewhere farmers benefited so did
consumers whose prodigious pork
consumption was subsidized by the sale
of cork by products I'm going to skip
over industrial farming because I think
that's been pretty well covered at this
at this conference I only want to point
out that the it's so recent modern
confinement agriculture what week what
we would call pastured pork today was
all pork in nineteen forty or so and I
just want to point out one statistic
this is from the USDA in 1950 there were
three million farms in the u.s. raising
hogs three million and in 2012 there
were about 50,000 so from three million
to 50,000 in about 65 years or so and my
final section is on pastured pigs Chuck
Talbot who has a PhD in animal science
and now raises pigs near Charleston West
Virginia runs a high-end curing
operation called woodlands pork the pigs
a blend of heritage breeds with some
wild boar mixed in spend their final
months in the woods eating acorns and
other wild foods then as partners
process and cure the meat producing a
pricey American ham to rival the best
from Europe Talbot explains the dilemma
of modern pork in these terms you've got
the rich farmers feeding the poor
families and the poor farmers feeding
the rich families which is to say big
corporations run by wealthy executive
sell bacon for three dollars a pound at
walmart while struggling farmers like
him offer it farmers
market for four times that price or
maybe they sell it at Chipotle Chipotle
which claims to use pork only from pigs
raised on pasture or in pet or in pens
with deep beds of straw released a
two-minute animate animated film titled
back to the start in 2011 the story
which has no dialogue begins with a
young farmer joined by his wife and baby
working a bucolic small farm with pigs
on pasture he then builds an enormous
factory where his pigs are pumped full
of feed and drugs before being packed
into boxes and driven away on trucks
finally an old man with a grown son the
farmer dismantles the factory and turns
it back into a farm with pigs on pasture
once again on the soundtrack Willie
Nelson sings a Coldplay song I'm going
to read this not not not sing it science
and progress don't speak as loud as my
heart I'm going back to the start it's a
heartwarming tale and not entirely
inaccurate in America and Europe a
growing number of farmers are embracing
more traditional forms of Agriculture
but that's only a small slice of the
story in the developing world especially
China and Brazil farmers are moving in
the opposite direction they're giving up
old-fashioned ways and raising pigs and
confinement barnes because they can make
a lot of money doing so in only the
latest controversy in the long history
of swine some people are tearing down
confining confinement barnes out of
ethical concerns as others raise them up
for financial reasons it's a question of
values and prices how much is a happy
pig worth thank
eight any comments on niman ranch being
bought by Purdue if that's something
you're familiar with the largest
cooperative of yeah mixed thoughts
mostly pessimistic as I think was
discussed at the round table last night
it's it's easy for big AG with a lot of
money to to co-opt good farming
practices I'm another part of me is
trying to be hopeful about it because
what it means is that people do care
about these things Chipotle when they
were first experience their their pork
shortage they had a problem last year
with with one of their suppliers not
following the the required protocols and
so they they had a disastrous nationwide
carnita shortage which and people there
was a lot of commentary that said this
this shows that this is bad for them but
I thought it was good it actually
highlighted that they were doing
something different that could cause
supply problems and so I I think the key
will be somebody needs to hold their
feet to the fire as has been discussed
previously the need for a third-party
certification systems to guarantee that
these things are actually what they say
they are and there's other steps that
could be taken like the vanishing of the
word natural from all meat packaging
yeah so I guess that just says that that
I have mixed feelings yeah obviously the
centrality of pigs to the pioneering
process of expansion in the United
States also suggest their sensuality to
the dispossession of resident indigenous
populations wherever that form of
Agriculture spread across the continent
I'm assuming we'll be hearing about this
to some degree tomorrow on the panel on
Imperial ISM and colonialism but in your
book and in your narrative of pigs and
and particularly in the United States
expansion
I was wondering if you could speak a bit
about pigs being part of that process of
dispossession and whether they were ever
specifically targeted when resident
indigenous populations resisted that
expansion um yeah that absolutely
happens I do discuss it in my book
there's a good there's a good book from
which I borrow liberally creatures of
empire Anderson is the name of the
author there and yeah they did so that
you read a lot of complaints about pigs
be spoiling the clam banks that that
indigenous peoples had relied on for
food routing up food caches that uh that
they had stored destroying there were a
lot of marsh lilies that were important
in in the diets of Aboriginal peoples
and and concerns I quote from a from an
official in a in Oregon who was very
concerned about starvation of some of
the native tribes there because the pigs
were destroying all of their food
resources the I don't I don't recall
anything about pigs being targeted it
was actually the one type of livestock
that a lot of Native Americans embraced
because they were so they were so easy
like a lot of times the colonists would
try to force cows upon them because it
would force them to adopt regular habits
they would like particularly dairy cows
you have to milk them regularly it but
they didn't want to have anything to do
with those because it was too much work
whereas as the deer we're disappearing
the pigs for Native Americans function
as as a replacement for deer you just
turned them loose in the woods and you
hunted them down when you needed them
and and you didn't you didn't have to
they like them for the same reason that
the early colonists and later pioneers
like them
I I just want to ask looking at the
whole heritage of you know the feral
swine that's been presented here today
it keeps coming in my mind and just kind
of an open thought that you know with a
new type of hogs all the hog producers
now are drawing from primarily one or
two genetic fields and in most states in
the US the feral hog is becoming extinct
or because they're thinking they're
diseased factors to these large
operations so you know what is going to
become in your opinion if we're growing
from one gene pool with genetics that
you know it's more on the confinement
building hog rather than heritage hog
what's going to become in the future
when we have nothing to draw from did
you say that I don't think that the
feral pigs certainly aren't in any
danger of being wiped out there they're
very they're very good at surviving
Texas has a couple million of them and
and and try as they might to eradicate
them they won't I actually I I'm
concerned about the the way industrial
hog producers raise their hogs but I
think that there are quite a few people
working on the conservation of of
heritage breeds I don't think that
that's actually one thing I'm generally
a pessimist but that's actually one
thing I'm optimistic about I think there
are more people preserving enough
animals to to serve as a reservoir for
when we when I hope we go back to more
sensible forms of agriculture on that
optimistic note we're going to move on
to the next panelist and we'll have some
more time at the end for conversation
okay oh I have to thank Jimin game and
everybody else for inviting me to this
really incredibly interesting
stimulating stop provoking conference
I've learned an enormous amount about my
own work as well as everybody else's
work and what I'm going to say is going
to dovetail directly out of some of the
things that mark said no Chuck tablet
figures in my work as well and and
diamond ranches is in this talk and goes
directly to the last question that we
had so without further ado let me thank
you let me thank you for that and also
point out that the work that I'm want to
speak about today as part of a book
that's currently impressed called real
pigs which is derived from a from field
researchers I carried out across central
North Carolina for six years looking at
small-scale pasture-raised production
processing marketing and consumption in
this time I came to understand that a
range of values and often rather diverse
even contradictory missions motivated
the many people that participated in
this local pork movement but I also
found that most of them from first
generation farmers to farmers market
customers to agricultural extension
officers characterized their work as in
some ways interested in as many of them
put it what they called being authentic
it's this pursuit of authenticity that
is the problem embedded in real pigs
that is the book them that I'm bringing
out more over the North or the
notoriously slippery value of
authenticity is also generally
understood by the folks I've worked with
to embody what many of them call a
connection a connection that people like
farmers and choppers and parents and
entrepreneurs hope to create or provide
or simply experience this can be a
connection with food with a landscape
with neighbors or with the lives and
welfare of pigs my comments today turn
on these ethnographic categories and
comp and commitments to authenticity as
it is graps grasped as a form of
connection and I hope to show how these
pigs committees commitments sorry are
understood and embodied in particular
what I'm calling genre of pig and that
is heritage breed pigs and a specific
kind of heritage breed pig at that
namely what you're looking at here the
AUSA ba island hog which we heard about
just yesterday as a these takes however
are
sentence of those feral pigs from
Ossabaw Island in his excellent study of
the evolutionary history of the
industrial hog Sam white who I gathers
book you're not too long ago describes
the way the Chinese stock played a
central role in the transformation of
the English Pig these small fat black
pigs from Asia introduced into Europe in
the early 18th century had been kept for
centuries converting household scraps
and agricultural leavings into edible
protein this physiological capacity made
them well-suited to improve the rangy
hairy European hogs that fed primarily
on forest mast by means of this
hybridizing encounter a burgeoning
market in southeastern England for
improved hogs raised in sties trough fed
and fattened on peas and beans when not
scavenging London's backyards would be
fed by farmers in the Midlands of
leicestershire and Lincolnshire now this
transformation in the hybrid English pig
was also a revolution in its symbolic
form the expansion of English markets
for pigs for pork facilitated by
newfangled pigs raised on farms
dedicated to their production with was
further facilitated by promoting
specific breeds of livestock which
allowed customers across England to
recognize those pigs with the
distinctive characteristics they
preferred so Robert bakewell a pioneer
in the promotion of life to livestock
breeds from the late 18th century held
that as he put it the new idea of breed
was from the beginning nothing more than
as he put it an ingenious marketing and
publicity mechanism and so the market
played a critical early role in the
formal informal eyes selective breeding
whether such ideas are never are ever as
he put it nothing more than a marketing
device is one of the questions I pursue
here the issues I raised for
contemporary North Carolina are relevant
for considering the relationship between
selection quality and reproduction it's
really the focus of what I'm going to
talk about here early adopters of these
Chinese pigs facilitated a proliferation
of English breeds across the countryside
how some of those pigs ended up as
heritage breeds while others are
relegated to the ignem industrial
standardization is itself an intriguing
historical question but in this talk I
address a slightly different problem
what kind of thing I ask is a heritage
livestock breed what is the purchase on
variation in forms of life that is
afforded to us by codifying specific
breeds and endow them with distinctive
qualities is
actually such semiotic ly charged
qualities as heritage addressing such
problems entails a consideration of the
relationship between the production of
livestock breeds and concomitant efforts
to market these animals and their meat
as idem as I demonstrate animal
production and marketing is a recursive
process as the criteria to which
livestock are bred may themselves be
transformed as discerning consumers seek
different characteristics as they put it
in the breed this recursive ax t is
relevant to an understanding of social
and cultural forms of tipa fication the
practices by which categories are and
are established and confirmed in social
life with the widest level I argue that
this concern with categories is a useful
way to think about questions of
materiality and immateriality breeds are
concepts that express preferences
interests and other conventional notions
all contingent on a variety of contexts
at the same time breeding animals to
these types is an intrinsically material
process requiring the skilled selection
of animals as well as a grasp of the
wider of wider husbandry practices
environmental conditions and and the
physiological well-being of particular
animals that are all conducive to
successful livestock reproduction what
is it then that is materialized in the
category of breed what concrete
qualities rendered in the crate are
rendered in the creation of heritage
breeds I argue that the distinction
between breeds as definitive types or
categories of life and breeding a
process of selection and bio social
reproduction and animal husbandry is
characterized by a number of tensions
that inform the production of category
categories like specialty or
occasionally here in England pedigree or
in the United States heritage and these
have implications for the social
conditions under which such animals are
produced and circulate so let's think a
little bit about the ausable Island hog
itself these pigs are descendants of the
Alberico pig or pata Negra originally
brought to the new world in 1539 with
Spanish colonial forces abandon and hero
showing on the map yeah there's ossible
island abandoned or perhaps shipwrecked
on the Atlantic coast a feral colony of
these e beijos survived in isolation
from the mess
sick pigs on the sea island of asaba
just off the coast of Savannah Georgia
which is right below so that in there
the island remain largely undeveloped
through the end of the 20th century and
the Hogs that are acquired the
characteristic qualities of something we
heard about this morning which namely
insular dwarfism becoming smaller and
overall size but possessed of a
remarkable physiological ability to
store fat this propensity has made this
heard of in this this particular heard
of interest to medical researchers
studying metabolic syndrome diabetes and
heart disease the first speaker began
moving and then actually actively
breeding Ossabaw hogs from us about from
ausable island in 2002 the medical uses
of the Ossabaw were facilitated by their
environmental impact on them asava
Island habitat as we also heard about
yesterday the porcine colony was making
a fishing use of the limited food
supplies on the island by voraciously
eating the eggs of such endangered
species as the loggerhead sea turtle any
number of nesting birds and assorted
often protected reptiles and amphibians
the Georgia Department of Natural
Resources developed a management plan in
2000 that actually called for the
eradication of the island's feral hog
population what would become the
heritage breed was only saved from this
fate by the medical interest in the Hogs
that began exporting the hogs from
possible Island and breeding them for
medical research the selective breeding
of Ossabaw Island hogs then is rooted in
a complex history one that extends from
a colonial expansion through
environmental management to biomedical
research the history of these hogs poses
some problems for the study of breeds
for example Ossabaw Alan hawse were
deposited on Ossabaw island in the mid
16th century well before the notion of
distinct recognizable livestock breeds
was developed in Europe in the course of
four hundred years of inbreeding and
environmental adaptation the Ossabaw
Island hog developed phenotypic and
perhaps the jury's a little bit perhaps
genotypic characteristics that
distinguish them as a possible as
population but it is entirely unclear
that the Iberian pigs had any such prior
connections to one another this fact
makes the in some ways obvious than by
no means trivial point that breeds as
such our historical phenomena yet the
Ossabaw presents the
perhaps anomalous history of being a
breed that was not selectively bred
through techniques of careful life
livestock husbandry but left to
naturally evolve through their
abandonment in a resource-poor
environment a long-term process that
generated animals which are both
physiologically compromised prone to
human like metabolic ailments and as it
turns out distinctively delicious this
genealogy seems to beg the question what
makes a breed of pigs a breed how do
their historical characteristics as a
breed give them a discernible heritage
and how I ask can we situate these
historical characteristics and qualities
within the transformations of central
North Carolina in political economy
demography and pig farming that is swept
that have swept across this this region
in recent decades and again goes
directly to Mark's point at the end
about the number of the vast number of
farms that once existed now the much
smaller number of harm's farms that
exist but the massive increase in the
population of those hogs on those on
those arms and so that North Carolina is
a is a story in miniature of exactly
that transformation one way to pursue
these questions is to look directly at
the discourse and activities of those
most interested in identifying and
promoting heritage breeds of swine so
here are my quote from a lengthy
conversation i had with program managers
of the livestock Conservancy in
pittsboro north carolina here i'm
quoting from a woman one of the bigger
things to tackle with pigs is not just
breeding them but bringing them
correctly so that you've got a good body
type good traditional body type and not
turning them into a commercial hog for
instance with the Berkshire the vast
majority amount of them out there are
not brochure they've got Hampshire in
them and they're kind of commercialized
at this point and so getting people to
understand that there's something to the
old body types and what's why that's
important for the particular breeds with
the swine initiative we're hoping to
create guidelines to help people
understand get people to understand okay
what are you looking at when you're
looking at the hog what's a good back
look like what's a good feet look like
what qualities should you insist upon
for your breeders it's like buyer beware
when you're buying hogs we tip we tell
people do your homework know what a good
hog looks like now this manager
emphasizes the way the breeds are
characterized by a particular one
to serve some good good hogs this
manager emphasizes the way that breeds
are characterized by us you put some
particular qualities moreover the notion
of qualities is especially apt in this
context as it entails both recognizable
characteristics as well as hierarchical
evaluation that is good hogs bred
correctly are preferable in some
recognizable ways to other pigs there is
as she says something to those old body
types this theme of quality is an
important one that resonates with the
claims and practices of farmers as well
as chefs and consumers working with
bastard pigs in their pork even the very
brief comments demonstrate the ways that
breeds and breeding are complicated by
marketing and commerce an abiding theme
in the breeding of livestock the
significance of heritage then needs to
be grasped as a term of distinction that
offers a contrast to the industrial
production of pigs that dominates the
state even as the term heritage also has
market value that facility facilitates
the production and productivity of
heritage breed pigs as commodities in
this way heritage carries with it the
uneasiness of alternative practices that
nonetheless depend upon wider structure
structures of practice to sustain them
heard of heritage pigs in other words
would have little value in the absence
of their industrial counterparts to more
relevant points we want to make first
the idea of breed Conservancy as a
practice that distinguishes one heritage
population from a commercial other
supports the values of authenticity that
are central to the ways that these
animals are marketed and that motivate
the practices of so many participants in
this niche such an unsullied line
connotes a sense of that which is
uniquely real and not modified or
corrupted for commercial or commodified
interests further it should also be
clear that in addition to plot implying
that holding oneself at a removed from
the market constitutes these animals and
husbandry practices as somehow more real
connecting Spanish and European as much
most heritage breeds are held to be of
English origin connecting Spanish
ancestry through u.s. geography to
contemporary North Carolina
practitioners provides a distinct and
different line of preservation one that
is also fit effectively rooted in blood
this lineage suggest that social
distinctiveness of the people who
inhabit this world equipped to
appreciate a heritage the something in
those bodies which
which they can also affiliate themselves
in this way these attributes of a breed
provide an alibi or materially
materialization of racial ideologies a
point that I addressed in more detail in
the book in that I might be able to get
you today enough time how do breeders
and those interested in livestock
breeding understand how the qualities
that distinguish a heritage breed are
embodied in these animals not just
conceptualized but embodied just what
was this something that distinguished
the old body types so I asked this time
in other managers are you conserving
genetics is that the idea and his
response was this well I think you're
preserving genetics but in preserving a
breed or the genetics of a breed you
have to be mindful of the management
style or the way the breeding herd is
maintained generation after generation
because the effects positively or
negatively are what we're selecting for
we're not just selecting for
confirmation we're selecting for
performance you know is it going to give
you the muscle or the fat the back fat
that you're looking for is it going to
be desirable by the end consumer chef
there's a lot of variables there end of
his quotation the overall performance of
the animal is the outcome of a selection
process that is carried out by certain
management techniques these questions of
performance are particularly important
because they reveal the ways that
selection is guided by efforts to
produce and reproduce identifiable
qualities that are simultaneously
features of animal lives old body types
good feet muscling as well as these
animals performance as desirable
consumable meet consideration of
performance in this way allows us to
situate breeding as well as the wider
value of heritage breeds and the
practices by which that value is
materialized in a wider context of
social activities seeing a breeding
process as directed by concern with what
is most desired by the end consumer
allows us to incorporate a wider network
of perspectives on chefs and consumers
in this network of perspectives is
really one of the frameworks that guides
my book at the whole as a whole at the
same time the very notion of performance
suggests an effort to carefully
distinguish heritage from commodity
forms even as the central qualities of
the heritage pig I realized when the pig
becomes in fact a consumable commodity
that's what performance means given its
use in the world in the world of life
dustrial Isaac which also has an
interest in performance using
performance in these ways creates a kind
of point of differentiation between
commercial production and heritage
breeding or if you like a kind of switch
point it applies to both forms but also
serves to differentiate them we might
say in this way performance is rather
like breed conservancy it points to an
effort to distinguish putatively real
porcine character and quality from
adulterated commodified purposes
performance then is a way to connect
certain qualifications while distancing
others in the form of heritage breeds
that are distancing heritage breeds them
as I said from industrial or and or
conventional types of animals now I
don't have time to discuss the way that
the perspectives of the pigs themselves
contribute to the cultivation of
qualities in the breeding process but I
do address that in the longer chapter so
I can I'm happy to talk about that if I
can now here I focus on quality and
performance terms that are used by
heritage pig breeders and activists to
describe their particular goals this
draws attention to the way that heritage
management is inextricably bound to
concerns with the commodification of the
pig of the pig and their pork that a
breed can be diminished by commercial
motivations and that performance can
only be evaluated by discerning
customers whose capacity for recognizing
quality occurs after the heritage breed
animal has been processed and rendered
as commodified meet with only the brief
time that I have left I want to show how
this tension between distinctive
qualities in the breed and the
commercial potential of these animals in
is embedded in the very category of the
breed itself I don't unfortunately have
time to address the fascinating
relationship between breeds and brands
that was proposed proposed to me by one
of the farmers that I work with but
instead I want to address the connection
between breeds and hybrids and return
once again to the awesome oz as I noted
above ours are small slow-growing fatty
pigs and on the particular farm that I
worked in in North Carolina where these
pigs are raised the office of oz are
often crossed with other breeds of pigs
in order to produce a faster growing
larger p now there's no attempt to deny
the presence of the non Ossabaw genetics
in a livestock that about it frees
nobody's trying to get away with
something until of these crossed animals
as pure awesome ah or to suggest that
the new form of heard that some that
you've created some new kind of heritage
breed you haven't
but rather what the farmers trying to do
is to recognize that the viability of
the asaba as a commercial form of
livestock an animal bred for the
performance of its pork depends on
expanding the potential of that heritage
breed at Cane Creek the pig of choice
was which to cross the Asafa is the one
that you're looking at here the farmers
hybrid a larger animal that yields cuts
of meats that can be sold more
profitable profitably than those from
pure osawa on farmers hybrid
much-beloved known by the name of Bill
Clinton the farmers hybrid is of much
water importance in national efforts to
revitalize natural and pest report
production as it was in fact critical to
the development of the Neyman ranch
brand because they promoted the use of
farmers hybrids for the farmers that
they were trying to do outreach with to
get into to start to raise pigs on
pasture as the non romantic brand
promoted so this is so again the the
hybrid the farmers hybrid itself entails
a wide network of perspectives and
network of discerning chefs retail
outlets like Whole Foods and farmers
that were familiar familiar or becoming
familiar with out there are production
practices so even if the hot farmers
harbored hybrid are not actually
cross-bred with these heritage breeds
like the asaba their presence is in fact
already built into the material
conditions that make such breeds
possible it's impossible to imagine
heritage breeds in the absence of
hybrids like this one which provide a
commercial outlet for the sale and
production and growth of raising
heritage breeds as prop as a commodity
form and so what this means is it as I
said this it's impossible to imagine
heritage breeds in the absence of
hybrids it's only once a definitive
characteristics of the properly
performing animals have been
materialized that the breed of that
animal can in fact be known through its
performance in this way a breed is the
product of hybridization grounded an
entangled history of improved breeding
techniques heritage prig simultaneously
confirm and challenge the impetus to
develop a commercial industry and
livestock their heritage is critical to
the niche standing but there we go
but this value-added position also
renders them vulnerable for the
temptation to commercialize the breed
through the specialized value that
heritage commands may lead to the loss
of the very genetic profile that defines
the heritage breed the importance of
performance in a breed provides the
opportunity for a series of
qualifications and wreak wolluf
occations as physiological and
anatomical features of a breed that can
be selected for which will in turn
permit the qualification of particular
kinds of products Bacon's loins fat etc
that can in turn be reek wallah fide via
for example value-added processing like
charcuterie cooking etc in addition to
performance then the role of hybrids in
livestock husbandry reveals how the
commercial viability of niche markets in
heritage breeds is underwritten by the
ongoing history of improvement and
transformation and not simply
preservation and continuity finally the
notion of breeds as brand which I
haven't elaborated on here provides a
means for both articulating and concrete
izing the values of direct force right
forms of social practice that provide an
alternative to the industrial food
system the care and craft of the
livestock breeder indeed the honest
later labour of an actual farmer you can
meet and look in the eye as many of the
customers that I work with what would
put it are conveyed in the way that
heritage brees serve to brand the
authenticity of these tactile encounter
so I'm actually demonstrating the own
authenticity of my productivity as well
by showing you the farmer at work in the
field as I or the anthropologist doing
fieldwork as it were the preference for
heritage report among these farmers
consumers and others committed to
innovation suggest the ways that
heritage works to provide a kind of
narrative of realness and unadulterated
unadulterated intentions yeah the
temporal depth incentive and during
place sought by in migrating innovators
and readily encountered in these porcine
forcing lives bespeaks the way that such
breeds embody a desire for preservation
amidst displacement they also indicate
as well the exclusionary potential of
such semiotic material processes through
the ascription for example a breed
Conservancy or the notion of an
ineffable something that distinguishes
crass commercial creatures from those
that are worthy of heritage in both of
these respect as sources of innovative
practice in
modes of socio semiotic differentiation
it's only a slight exaggeration to
suggest that today's food after
activists quite closely resemble the
ausable hogs themselves transplanted
into New Territories their exceptional
qualities can be reckoned recognized and
cultivated as they introduce new
possibilities for remaking their local
order a bunch of Duke grats I might add
of outsiders made local we might say
both esteemed qualities swine with
heritage entrepreneurial farmers with
local sustainability locavores with
ethical concerns they all craft an
innovative future so thank you very much
I wanted to thank rad and we have five
inch questions and then five minutes for
conversation because I'm under strict
instructions that we have to be out of
here by for the coffee break at quarter
to so thanks Brad um that was great um I
have a question about well so in
addition to the breed as brand on which
you know goes back to bake well um
there's also the sense of breed as
transmission that breed is and this is
in some of the sources that I've looked
at breed is a metaphor in a way for
inheritance that it that some people say
it was adopted or they say but they're
saying at the turn of the 19th century
it was adopted precisely because it
denotes transmission in a way that race
didn't at the time for instance right
because people did call them races of
livestock and that gonna be thinking
about metaphors for inheritance which is
a something that seems at least to be
resolved when we enter the era of kind
of modern genetical knowledge and DNA
and the ausable pigs that you're talking
about there's you know we feel like we
have a firm grasp on how their traits
how their qualities are actually
conveyed from generation to generation
but it's very striking to me that the
farmers you're the producers you're
working with are using many of the same
metaphors that people used prior to this
you know modern so-called modern
knowledge so that was an observation
that I'd love to get your take on and
but the question attached to that
is given that the AUSA buzz like a
little bit of an outlier or an
interesting case in heritage breeds
because of its medical its utility as a
medical model how different is the
breeding the Hogs that are the animals
that are bred to model like diabetic
humans how different is that from the
way that they're bred and is the
language different and liara what was
the uncle tell me the metaphor that you
used again is transmission is that oh
yeah I can I can I can look up the
quotation for you but it's like but
breed but livestock breeders adopt breed
in part because it denotes a sense of
transmission absent elsewhere that's
part of what I'm trying to capture by
pointing out the distinction between
breeds and breeding and that breeds
implies a sort of a type a category but
when you get into the practice of
breeding you're talking about something
that is more that that is emergent
because it has to do with it's like you
know like as when we talk about somebody
who has good breeding for example right
we mean something that's cultivated we
mean something that's produced over time
and the course of their lives through
the cultivation and engendering of
particular kinds of qualities and the
way let's talk about by these master
breeders by these livestock people is
what they call performance and that's
not at all the genetic heritage of these
animals i mean the genetic heritage of
these awesome Boz is highly dubious I
mean it's extremely problematic nobody
you know until 2002 nobody was carefully
monitoring the now it's there's a pretty
good assumption it's a small insular
population that for 400 years has been
in one place they're all genetically
typical identity well you know they
share their broadly widely shared it's
not how clear it is the how different
they are genetically that's why I sort
of emphasize phenotype much more than
much much more than genotype as even as
these breed folks do as well but they
emphasize that how important it is to
keep you know what they're trying to
when they talk about preserving a breed
they talk about how a breed is not and
this is where I was trying to push
against this notion you know how a breed
is not the product of a mixture it
really has these distinctive qualities
that get preserved at the same time they
recognize that well it gets preserved by
husbandry not so much by that's
much by there was something else that
you are that's not too much by genetics
per se not pure next there's some other
point that you bet you that you've got
to that I wanted to that I want to speak
about as well and I can't recall what it
is now because it was such a rich
question but anyway start about that
yeah ordinarily I try not to make
comments without questions but I'm going
to make a comment without a question I
what I wanted to add a word of caution
to your what i thought was optimistic
last sentence or two the actual
real-world breeding of heritage breed
pigs is unfortunately very careless the
vast majority of people that are
currently breeding heritage breed pigs
are like i am was new farmers who are
not aware of the science and technique
behind breeding and so what they're
doing is Sal will have eight piglets
let's say a heritage breed salad glasser
old spot let's say we'll have eight
piglets and this so-called breeder will
offer eight piglets for sale as breeding
stock when in fact maybe one of them is
valuable as breeding stock yep and so
the future of the heritage breeds is
actually a little bit questionable
because we're losing all of the
qualities that heritage breeds had to
careless breeding and so that's
something that I I do not mean to imply
that absolutely affirms what I would I
what I'm trying to say as well I mean
for one thing that's exactly why there
is a livestock breed Conservancy because
there is this recognition as the manager
says from right from the beginning you
know you've got to be careful because
the because heritage itself has
commercial value that is you when you
say I'm raising a Berkshire pig I'm ring
raising gloucestershire old spot what
you're doing is you're creating a market
niche even as you're trying to
distinguish yourself from you know the
perils of commercialization what you're
doing is commercializing that that type
that that breed and your
absolutely right and the woman I work
with you Ray Suze za Sabah's is really
worried because and she more or less has
stopped providing feeder pigs or you
know breeders for for other folks
because she said you know they're
running down the genetics is the way
that is the way the farmers and and
other actors would put it that they you
know that they end up as she said
squirrely pigs they go slightly
stir-crazy or they're not you know and
again it's because it or two reasons
that that I think I'm trying to get at
in this paper one that that there's this
that the temptations of
commercialization are extremely strong
and there's norma's pressures to you
know to create a market for for these
kinds of pigs and to that it isn't as
you said these are new farmers and it's
really not an Conservancy is not
primarily about just some the genetic
transmission of information it's also
about husbandry and it's also about care
and craft in the technique that use so
all I was trying to say in the end is is
that both you're absolutely right that's
that's who these farmers are these are
new and so I was sort of joking with gav
about these are a bunch of folks in
North Carolina that are as everybody
would say is from New Jersey right I
mean um and they are they are they are
displacing a local population or maybe
they just can get access to let and
they're interested in the science and
the geography and the history of this
region and they're so so they're trying
to craft a place for themselves in place
by virtue of their connection to these
pigs whose place in this area also have
to has to be crafted I mean what did I'm
not sure what it is about a shipwrecked
Spanish pig that gives it heritage in
North Carolina other than other than
heritage breeders breeding them and
that's what I was trying to get it that
both of them together are crafting a
sense of their commitment to place in
this area they're both they're both
invasive species right they're both
invasive breeds right as people and as
and as as as pigs all right so I
actually I totally agree with with that
your assessment and that is in fact a
very real risk that that people i
knoweth who are good breeders really
really worried about right that
somebody's going to run down the
genetics of these animals so if i can
invite mark back to the front we have
time for two or
three more questions for either of
panelists and then I will have to cut us
off so we'll take the two or three
questions and let the answers come so
I'm going to take a quick second plug
marks book for him it's really good i
recommend it to all of you and my
question is you end the book talking
about how we should the path forward is
that we should accept that pork just
shouldn't be as cheap as it is and so
that's sort of like a consumer approach
that we talked about some yesterday and
trying to get people who can afford it
to pay more and I'm not as worried about
the social injustice aspects of that
because I think currently the
externalities of our commercial hog
industry are being born
disproportionately by impoverished
minority communities so that's injustice
as well so I think people should be
paying more for pork and eating less of
it but I'm not necessarily as optimistic
that that is going to actually pave a
path for that is better and so you know
I quote is we only have so much capacity
so I'm spending a lot of my capacity
takings or more marketing and education
approach trying to produce such a good
quality pork product and being able to
try to scream it from the rooftops and
educate people about why it's better to
get them to pay more for it but then you
could also spend your time focusing on
changing regulation and trying to
approach it that way so do you think we
should put sort of most of our emphasis
on trying to get people to pay more
should we you know how do we how do we
appropriately spend our time to try to
create this better path forward you know
return to the beginning like you talk
about
great well I'll a minute both respond
and then we'll be done um I would say
the consumer model in the states is
about the only viable model because the
chances of there being any regulatory
changes are are almost nil so there's a
reason that that people in the industry
call this niche meet I mean it's always
going to be I think it's always going to
be small I think it can get bigger but I
don't think it's going to get vastly
bigger and so I would say that your
model of educating people and persuading
people there there are improvements that
could be made simply as demand increases
you can get economies of scale such as
those realized by nine and ranch and a
couple of others on a smaller scale but
then again as we learn also learned
about Nyman ranch with scale comes a
move towards industrialization which
which increases which raises the chances
of other problems so yeah keep doing
what you're doing if I can if I can jump
it on that too I'm actually sort of all
hands on deck I mean any of any sort of
there's no perspective that I think is
not potentially fruitful basically
because it is such an uphill slog but
one thing I would say about regulation
is and then North Carolina is just a
classic example of this I mean it was
really in the 1980s in the mid-nineteen
eighties there was a very clear
concerted and well funded effort to get
big and that took some very specific
pieces of legislation that had
astronomical of overwhelming effects and
one might say well it may take some
pieces of legislation to correct that
and that so it's not I mean these are
these are socially and politically
constructed systems and it will take
social tactical movements to to move
them back I'm my optimistic about that
not in the short term nor am i
optimistic about niche markets either I
mean for the very same reasons that
they're that at the level of skill I
mean they can
education can be effective but and and
and efforts to expand direct marketing
for example can be can be effective but
they are by definition direct marketing
by definition is a really small scale
operation I work with a couple and I
know that mark noses well there's some
folks we're doing some really
interesting stuff in aggregation and
trying to reach out to people who have
hardly any animals at all and create
markets for them and make it possible
for them to actually if not make a
living at least make make money off of
the the production of their of their
sock and that what i like about those
efforts is it really they are really a
very conscientious about scale and the
recognition that you know the farm like
this one is a one of the most successful
farms in the in the list in the Piedmont
in North Carolina and if they have AV
customers they're really happy right so
what can we do to get you know to reach
out to 300 customers as opposed to the
ati i'm so again as i say all hands on
deck I i I'm just happy to have anybody
yeah yeah i agree i think it so much i
mean i think that's part of a contribute
that's what makes us feel as though it
is going to continue to be a niche at a
certain level I think I mean I don't
think Smithfield cares at all about
whether people by niche market pork you
know it's like that's fine we'll come up
with some other way to sell it to you
right or we won't even you know we don't
really even care about pork we just care
about our financial structures and the
debts in the contracts that we're
working out i mean the meat is totally
second there right so it's that mean to
me that's that's beyond pessimistic
that's just nihilistic but i think it's
not untrue I mean so I'm going to give
Jim the last word and then we'll take a
camera so heavy burdened hahaha the I
just had a simple question Oh which is
one wonders whether in the long run
given agribusiness and it's deep pockets
whether one is going to have a situation
in which a small scale heritage breed
artisanal producers end up tail
during the structure of their business
and their marketing model and so on in
order to become attractive enough to be
swallowed by a larger agribusiness and
in the kind of software industry that is
the kind of model you simply dress for
the dance convinced the people that
you've got something that may be worth
something or worth swallowing so it
doesn't become worth something and so
that is a kind of backward colonization
of the business model of artisanal
production that seems to me to have some
disturbing consequences the aggregator
that I was talking about was she was
this couple woman that run this company
and then and one of them was telling me
that she won't she had recently been to
a small conference for for startups and
she was totally dismayed because of
exactly that model that these are a
bunch of people who had invented some
apps and some software and what they
really hopefully couldn't wait for
Microsoft it just swoop in and give him
you know you may make them all fortune
and she wanted just the opposite of that
she wanted to just continue to grow
small and and spread with using the
exact same model that she had but she
realized it was that was not there was
there wasn't even an infrastructure that
was out there to support that notion
think that's not what business is
supposed to be about um and uh it and
that's I think that's part of what
people what makes people worry about the
the commercialization of heritage itself
make people sort of feel like well
that's you know and there will be I mean
three the smithfield in 2009 came out
with a line of pasture pork it didn't go
very far they sort of realized ended in
their beds but they were perfectly they
were they were like oh well list that it
is after all just one more niche so
that's great we can we can market that
in that way it'll work fine and I'd say
it and anytime anytime that happens I
give to the to the extent that that's a
model that works it it creates a new
opening for somebody else who's going to
brand themselves as that much more
authentic and and also this touches on
what Jennifer said before as well that I
mean I actually think that there may be
is a possibility of persuading people
to buy more expensive meat simply
because like food is never just
sustenance food always has a lot of
symbolic value among them status and and
I don't some people are buying
well-raised pork because it conveys
status upon them and I don't have any I
don't have any problem with that and
it's the thing about status is that
people tend to aspire to to higher
levels of status so if if that is what
it takes to persuade people to buy more
of the kind of pork you're raising then
even an anti elitist like me is
comfortable with that and about to give
attendance in spiders